STUFF IN SPITE OF FEAR, IN SPITE
OF THAT ADRENALINE THAT'S
PUMPING AND TELLING YOU THINGS.
SHIMON, I APPRECIATE THE
REPORTING, AS ALWAYS.
A DAY AFTER THE SHOOTING, I
SPOKE IN UVALDE WITH ANGEL
GARZA, WHO'S STEP DAUGHTER,
AMERIE JO WAS MURDERED AT ROB
ELEMENTARY A WEEK AND A HALF
AFTER SHE CELEBRATED HER 10th
BIRTHDAY.
I SPOKE WITH HIM TONIGHT BEFORE
THE SCHOOL BOARD MEETING.
ANGEL, THIS REPORT THAT WAS
RELEASED OVER THE WEEKEND,
HEARING ABOUT THE MYRIAD
FAILURES THAT TOOK PLACE, AND
THERE'S STILL OBVIOUSLY A LOT TO
LEARN.
WHAT DO YOU -- WHAT DID YOU
THINK WHEN YOU SAW THAT REPORT?
>> IT'S JUST -- IT'S
DISAPPOINTMENT.
I MEAN, IT'S, I GUESS,
CLARIFICATION THAT STUFF WE
ALREADY KNEW BUT GETTING THE
CLARIFICATION DOES MAKE IT A
LITTLE HARDER.
ALL OF THIS STUFF IS HARD.
EVERY TIME SOMETHING COMES OUT,
IT'S JUST LIKE RELIVING THE
SITUATION OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
>> HOW HAVE YOU GOTTEN THROUGH
THE LAST FEW WEEKS?
>> MY -- MY WIFE, MY SON, AND
ACTUALLY THE PARENTS OF THE
OTHER -- THE FAMILIES OF THE
REST OF THE VICTIMS, WE ACTUALLY
ALL HAVE COME TOGETHER AND
SPOKEN TO ONE ANOTHER.
AND WE'RE -- WE'VE REALLY BECOME
A FAMILY OF OUR OWN AND WE HELP
EACH OTHER AS MUCH AS WE CAN.
>> I DON'T THINK I'VE EVER
REPORTED ON A TRAGEDY LIKE THIS
IN WHICH THE FAMILIES HAVE BEEN
KEPT IN THE DARK FOR SO LONG
BY -- BY EVERYONE, IT SEEMS.
AND EVEN AT THIS STAGE, THE LACK
OF ANSWERS, DO YOU FEEL THAT?
ARE YOU -- AT THIS STAGE, WHAT
DOES ACCOUNTABILITY LOOK LIKE
FOR YOU?
>> EVERYBODY SAYS THAT.
PEOPLE TELL ME THAT THEY'VE
NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE THIS.
AGENCIES ARGUING AMONGST EACH
OTHER, TRYING TO POINT THE
FINGER ON WHO DID THIS AND WHO
DID WHAT.
HIGHLAND PARK HAPPENED AFTER US,
AND WE ALREADY KNOW EVERYTHING
ABOUT THAT.
WE KNOW EVERYTHING AT ALL.
I MEAN, WE KNOW EVERYTHING.
SO, IT MAKES NO SENSE THAT THERE
IS STILL THINGS THAT ARE
UNANSWERED ABOUT THIS.
IT'S -- IT'S HUMILIATING TO US.
IT MAKES US FEEL LIKE OUR KIDS
CAN'T REST IN PEACE.
ALL THIS ARGUING AND BICKERING
AND LYING TO OUR FACE, IT'S --
IT DOESN'T HELP OUR SITUATION AT
ALL.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE THAT THE TRUTH
WILL COME OUT IN THE END?
>> I GUESS THAT'S ALL US PARENTS
ARE HOPING FOR.
WE WANT TO, YOU KNOW, FIGHT
UNTIL WE DO GET THE ANSWERS THAT
WE'RE LOOKING FOR.
WE DESERVE THAT.
OUR CHILDREN DESERVE THAT.
THAT'S REALLY WHAT IT'S ABOUT.
WE JUST -- WE WANT OUR BABIES TO
REST IN PEACE.
WE WANT TO KNOW SO WE CAN GRIEVE
PROPERLY, SO WE CAN TRY TO MOVE
FORWARD AND TRY TO START A NEW
NORMAL.
I MEAN, NOBODY'S EVER GOING TO
BE THE SAME AFTER THIS.
>> ONE OF THE OFFICIALS A COUPLE
OF WEEKS AGO WAS SORT OF
CORNERED BY ONE OF OUR
REPORTERS, SHIMON PROKUPECZ.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS HE SAID TO
OUR REPORTER WAS THAT HE WOULD
SPEAK AND RELEASE INFORMATION
ONCE THE FAMILIES STOPPED
GRIEVING.
AND WHEN I HEARD THAT, I
THOUGHT, WELL THAT'S --
THAT'S -- THERE'S NEVER GOING TO
BE A TIME WHEN THAT PAIN IS NOT
THERE.
I'M WONDERING IF YOU HEARD HIM
SAY THAT AND WHAT YOU THOUGHT
WHEN YOU HEARD THAT.
>> I ACTUALLY DIDN'T.
I WASN'T AWARE OF THAT.
I MEAN, HEARING -- I THINK US
PARENTS THINK THAT HEARING
PEOPLE, YOU KNOW, RELEASE
INFORMATION OR KEEP INFORMATION,
THEY'RE DOING IT FOR US.
IT'S A COMPLETE LIE.
IF THEY HAVE INFORMATION AND
THEY WANT TO TELL US AS A
FAMILY, THEN TELL US AS A
FAMILY.
DON'T RELEASE IT TO THE PUBLIC.
DON'T, YOU KNOW, TRY TO GET
RECOGNITION OFF OF A SITUATION
LIKE THAT BECAUSE THAT JUST
HUMILIATES US.
WE LOST OUR CHILDREN.
THIS ISN'T SOMETHING THAT, YOU
KNOW, SOMEBODY SHOULD BE GAINING
ANYTHING OFF OF.
>> YOU'RE ABOUT TO GO INTO THE
FIRST SCHOOL BOARD MEETING SINCE
YOUR DAUGHTER AMERIE JO WAS
KILLED.
WHAT ARE YOU HOPING WILL HAPPEN
THERE?
WHAT ARE YOU EXPECTING?
>> I'M EXPECTING ACTUALLY A LOT
OF ANGRY PARENTS.
APPARENTLY, THERE WAS CHANCES
TO, YOU KNOW, FIX THE SECURITY
SYSTEM OR FIX THE LOCKS AT
LEAST.
AND THEY WERE JUST IGNORED.
AND A LOT OF PARENTS ARE PRETTY
UPSET ABOUT THAT.
SO, I EXPECT A LOT OF PARENTS
JUST TO GIVE THEM A PIECE OF
THEIR MIND.
HOPEFULLY THEY LISTEN.
EVERYBODY, YOU KNOW, SAYS THAT
THEY WANT TO HELP US.
WELL, IF THEY LISTEN TO US AND
THEY, YOU KNOW, MAKE CHANGE,
THEN THAT WILL DEFINITELY GIVE
US SOME TYPE OF HAPPINESS.
>> THE FIRST DAY OF THE NEW
SCHOOL YEAR IN UVALDE WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE FOUR WEEKS FROM
TODAY.
I UNDERSTAND THAT'S GOING TO BE
ANNOUNCED TONIGHT THAT IT WON'T
BE UNTIL SEPTEMBER NOW.
IN YOUR MIND, HAS ANYTHING AT
ALL CHANGED TO MAKE PARENTS FEEL
SAFE TO SEND THEIR KIDS BACK TO
SCHOOL?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
I FEEL, IF ANYTHING, I MEAN,
IT'S -- IT'S GETTING WORSE.
THE LACK OF KNOWLEDGE, THE LACK
OF JUST IT SEEMS LIKE URGENCY.
EVERYBODY SAYS, THIS IS GOING TO
TAKE TIME, THIS IS GOING TO TAKE
TIME.
WE'RE AT THE END OF JULY.
SCHOOL IS GOING TO BE HERE
BEFORE THEY KNOW IT, AND NOBODY
WANTS TO SEND THEIR CHILDREN TO
SCHOOL AFTER THIS.
I MEAN, WHO -- WHO WOULD WANT TO
SEND THEIR CHILDREN TO SCHOOL?
I SENT AMERIE TO SCHOOL THAT
MORNING THINKING I WAS GOING TO
PICK HER UP THAT DAY.
SO, WHO'S GOING TO BE
COMFORTABLE ENOUGH TO KNOW THAT
THEIR CHILD IS GOING TO BE OKAY
FOR THEM TO PICK THEM UP THAT
DAY?
>> YOU HAVE A SON.
WILL YOU BE SENDING HIM TO
SCHOOL GIVEN WHERE THINGS STAND?
OR HOW DO YOU MAKE THOSE
CHOICES?
>> AS OF RIGHT NOW, OUR SON WILL
PROBABLY BE HOME SCHOOLED.
HE'S NOT GOING TO BE GOING TO
SCHOOL RIGHT NOW.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH.
HE'S HAVING A LOT OF JUST
SEPARATION ISSUES HIMSELF.
SO, WE JUST WANT TO TAKE CARE OF
OUR FAMILY RIGHT NOW AND ALL THE
OTHER FAMILIES THAT ARE AFFECTED
BY THIS.
>> ANGEL GARZA, I REALLY
APPRECIATE TALKING TO YOU.
I AND WISH YOUR FAMILY CONTINUED
STRENGTH IN THE DAYS AHEAD.
>> THANK YOU, MR. COOPER.
THERE IS ONE THING I WANT TO ADD
BEFORE I LET YOU GUYS GO.
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF CONFUSION
ON THE SUBJECT OF AMERIE AND HER
BIOLOGICAL FATHER.
I'M NOT AMERIE'S BIOLOGICAL
FATHER, NEVER CLAIMED TO BE
AMERIE'S BIOLOGICAL FATHER.
AMERIE HAS A BIOLOGICAL FATHER,
AND SHE KNEW SHE HAD A FATHER,
AND SHE LOVES HIM.
I WILL NEVER TRY TO DISCREDIT
ANYONE IN THIS SITUATION AT ALL.
I REFER TO MYSELF AS DADDY
BECAUSE I EARNED THAT.
SHE CALLED ME THAT.
THE MORNING I DROPPED HER OFF,
SHE SAID, I LOVE YOU, DADDY.
I -- THAT'S THE ONLY REASON I
REFER TO MYSELF AS DADDY BECAUSE
I'VE BEEN WITH KIMBERLY SINCE
SHE WAS EIGHT MONTHS OLD.
AND SHE'S LIVED WITH US THE
ENTIRE TIME.
SO, I JUST WANTED TO CLEAR UP
THE AIR FOR ANYBODY.
I'M NOT TRYING TO DISCREDIT
ANYONE.
I'M JUST A GRIEVING STEPFATHER.
>> I UNDERSTAND.
THAT'S CERTAINLY NOT A QUESTION
WE EVER RAISED, BUT I UNDERSTAND
MAYBE SOMEBODY DID A LONG TI